hello welcome to another games ball
plays I'm Daniel Dwyer Eric Tay what's
up man what the goddamn hell is going on
I don't even know I think it's a game
called on a chambra Z to chaos it's back
the fever dreams of only chamber of
bikini samurai squad on the Xbox 360
I've come to a new generation of
consoles only chambra Z to chaos the
American release of a game that came out
last year what the what the [ __ ] that
today what the [ __ ] is this it's not
real Erik this is weird help last
generation I know
no no well ok well these are local
column here this is the weapons so like
just a top level what type of game is
this it's like a dynasty warriors run
like dynasty warriors except I would say
yeah so you're controlling more than one
character at one time and like you see
you'll have four characters yeah and
they all mean yep sake saya ayan Kagura
great they each have different weapons
hmm ah you know and you get to switch
between these weapons sweet what are you
doing in this area is this some sort of
like this is like the shop so to speak
so you can buy things with the orbs you
collect everything and you can buy
combos and stuff the orbs presumably
from killing zombies yep killing the
undead spirits that are trying to ravage
the world and that's who we're trying to
stop how dare they it's a good thing
we're wearing no clothing yet Jesus
Christ so this is like one of the
outfits that you can get you can
customize as you want so let's just do
one really quickly sure customers today
so there's multiple outfits right now
she's wearing cherry blossoms there's
rice this is so rad you can you know
spin around and whatnot don't need to do
that yeah I have uh and I don't have to
show all parts of the game and so this
is part of the I think it's like
strawberry banana split collection or
something like pre-order or something
this is collectors oh no oh no kind of
we know it gets a real risque if you got
the risk a swimsuit with risque that's a
banana banana it's a banana
that's a banana it's open right okay
it's pocket of this this pocket it's
like out of this just get back to
something a little bit more decent right
okay you can do either
on stone my god how did this get allowed
you can have to have a run around with
toast Wow
yeah and you can like what whatever
reason you can like move like so the
toast will be out here while we play
okay well I don't know so they allow you
to customize things to the level where
you can break physics yeah pretty much
what school I'm at can we just rein it
back a little bit okay we skipped over
the banana thing what the what the [ __ ]
is the toast thing about it's just a
Japanese thing it's like it yes it's
like mangas and stuff like that I just
tuck girls with toast in their mouths
yeah they run around like like you know
they're it's they're running to school
you know they have breakfast in their
mouth so they have a good piece of toast
like something you put her these elbow
guards like or they're supposed to be
like armed guards you can put them like
on her elbows so let's just do one more
here glasses and shin guard shin guards
and some like really funky positions
like that like ah between their legs I
guess or something it's on the ground
why do they let you do that I don't know
I have no idea you can mess with a Z
plane so yeah sure let's see if you
animate did they like flail where her
legs would be then I don't know we're
about to find out I didn't actually try
to put this stuff in we're okay let's do
a couple more than you should I get some
more yeah it's just DVI one are really
some really oops some real just like
kids get in there yep just climbing up
real go just make this one girl make no
sense whatsoever
alright so let's uh it's a glasses on
like stick away from our face maybe sure
none of it goes just do that in it just
like or to make the massive like them
and go to scale scale yeah hit that
scale just make him make him huge I
don't know how to make it I don't know
how to do it faster other than it was
hitting up pretty good there pretty big
make him there make him make him Lamech
I'm tall and then make him think of Z
doesn't make him D that him is that him
up right yeah that's great look at that
look at those glasses want to you want
to keep it where it's at though you
don't want to like have it like this no
no now now push it like five feet away
from her face alright you got some sort
of weird mystical Sally Jessy Raphael oh
wait hold on that was just to get it out
that's good no that's good yeah okay
sure yeah just floatable right yep yep
yep
let's let it go yeah right okay all
right let's go all right let's go do a
story cry so you've completed this
already right yeah I was about like four
or five hours or something that it gets
like longer later I'll just do one of
these shorter missions since I bet it
gets longer and I played bikini Samurai
squad and back in the day on the Xbox
360 and my primary sort of get away from
playing those games was hack and slash
like kind of to the dynasty Warriors
level sorry
dynasty Warriors level of like I don't
really know what I'm doing what I'm just
hitting the buttons does that feel like
it's the same here or is there any
skills
there's combo yeah and there's like
little things you can do where you can
kind of have one girl like finishing her
combo and then interact with the other
ones and then the another girl will come
out and start attacking and like
basically you'll see this combo meter
that you're trying to like maintain and
try to keep it as okay okay and then
there's also other things where you know
you can call on all of them to help you
I can it's loading can you flick between
these two oh yeah good let's go
chapter six division of the rotting soul
yeah so I forget what this is [ __ ]
Cal yeah sure yeah yep I want to see
your shim pods the most actually oh no
no I could have been worse rashim pods
oh they're kind of like slightly to the
left
I don't know side of each of her right
now
oh Jesus what's happening to her she
hogs
I don't know so there's a light in a
medium attack and then there's also yeah
so this is kind of more or less what it
is well I hack and slash there are dog
buttons this is super colorful actually
yeah yeah it's alright the camera is
kind of weird cause like I have to
actually either
here's the right thumbstick to kind of
like change it I mean which is weird
because you're trying to like semi mash
like square and triangle right yeah so
some of the bosses are kind of weird and
their lock on camera so to speak is like
r1 so like but you have to hold it right
like it doesn't like what you like it so
if you if you tap on one it's just like
goes back seems to hold or one while
you're circling yep
wait I can use like can you dive and
then the dive is based on where the your
lock is like you know like blood-borne
style just like like lock and dive lock
it lock and evade rather it doesn't stay
lock okay so like unless I hold on to
our one like this it's not gonna stay
right but then you want to try to keep
hitting the other guys so I don't know
so like okay I did too early but you can
you can combo like I said during one of
these like square animations sweet go up
there oh yeah so she's still doing stuff
bring in another girl dealer girls came
him nowhere yeah you can either hit down
up on the d-pad and then another girl
will come out so she's still doing that
yeah girl that's not good
yeah that guy's I don't know is it the
monsters aren't very hard and this is I
think on Normal difficulty these
monsters from like from like the Pacific
War or something I don't remember the
direct of these guys or why there's even
Pearl Harbor to start but yeah every
character has two weapons so she was
using up this weapon at one point we're
then now she has a one longsword BAM
pretty cool
are the weapons locked to the characters
yeah they usually have two specific
kinds for this character she has the
melee knuckles and then she has the
longsword and then the other characters
there have like two a wield sword and a
single sword or Hanlin see in this
girl's case she had a chainsaw cool
which is pretty cool she actually liked
one of my like the favorite out of the
four I guess I don't know why I did I
think it's just like because she's
wearing the least amount of clothes Erik
no I could have been bikini or what was
it the strawberry banana split it could
have been yeah I did
I don't know I think the just a reverb
of the chainsaw it's just like multiple
yeah I kind of like that actually it
didn't yeah and the other thing about
this game is like see how I clean the
chainsaw because you know there's too
much zombie blood yes slowing me down is
slowing my damage now that's grits and
your machinery get them out and then you
can do this like charging attack yeah
that one's pretty cool but yeah exactly
I get far enough and I can show you some
other stuff yeah so bikini time my squad
was as far as I remember was a full
flash game I remember when these
originally came out in Japan these were
budget titles and that xcd were putting
out it was d3 with the publisher what is
the what is the money status is this a
full-priced video I believe so okay you
don't have sent $60 for the actual game
and then an 80 for the collectors oh
great is that there's always you get the
banana split situation yeah and then you
get a Jose that like soundtrack you may
be in art books grace yeah that's whoa
what the [ __ ] happen here this voice
coming out of your ps4 controller yeah
she's your Intel person okay she kind of
guides you and tells you what to do um
yeah she's cool she's your mailing I
guess yeah okay you can also go let's
see if I have it I think I have it I can
also I don't have it but you can also
kind of go like super saiyan mode and
they'll like turn like demon ish okay
yes I remember that actually yeah so but
yeah it's it's pretty much like a
Dynasty Warriors game with a little bit
more layers of you know you can do
combos you can switch between the
characters you can earn you combo so I
mean I guess you kind of have that in
Dynasty Warriors too but at least with
this it's like you can have multiple
character interactions you can bring
them all on the screen at one time whoa
just oh no fair yeah so you played these
completed this game over the course wars
are like five hours or so five or six
hours ago did you have a fun time Eric
tag ah is this a fun time because this
looks pretty brainless to me although
you do like playing destiny so I don't
know destiny has definitely a lot more
thinking than this sorry it's okay uh I
think it's fun for a little bit the
Carmack's actually not that bad
I wish the dodging mechanic was
I mean it's good but the enemies don't
really attack you that often and you
don't feel like you're getting like
attack other than when you fight the
bosses right and so I wish that was kind
of better especially since after coming
from like blood-borne and stuff you know
like it was so critical that you dodged
and then like yes good Punisher you know
your opponent for a good guy or like
Bayonetta you know yeah it felt
satisfying it like doing okay I dodge
the game's gonna reward me yeah
plaintiff is a good example I think of
anything so this is just kind of like
whoa another mill hack-and-slash look my
classes that are way above my head like
it doesn't look right for a for a next
like the environments look this for this
particular bar looks for the fraud but
I'm actually kind of impressed by the
frame rate and how the characters look
actually I think my bar was set super
low though coming out of the experience
that I had with the bikini samurai
squash which had a loading gain a
loading screen game that was actually
better than that in the game itself
that's rough yeah I remember I'm
thinking it's really weird that they
have a loading screen game because that
pavement hadn't finished yet but then I
think Bandai Namco like bought the
developer like three months later so
yeah that was like fun you got ranked V
what's be Stanford victory I don't know
if it's actually victory be for victory
that's the highest you can get let me
see if I get to the boss at least should
be right you want to kill the boss don't
you do the boss right I don't know maybe
right this is oh yeah I mean it huh yeah
well I don't know I think that's I think
that's given the only time Barra see to
chaos maybe a bit too much this mantra
credit not saying in terms of gameplay
oh I don't know I don't know can you
kill a boss now all right we can be done
I'll see what I can do we do this kill
like oh yeah let me call my friends she
got this any games would mean all of
them oh wait you stunned us yeah way to
switch to the little 15 year old zoo
camp it was on the ground
no she's right there are these where are
these where's that growth parent like
the rest of them look like they're
probably old enough to be out doing this
other thing because she's like she's
live with two young I don't know I mean
she's one of the assassins actually is
you can believe it or not I'm
referencing the Laura's if I've any idea
what you're talking about I don't know
because you asked me where her parent
was and trying to tell you she doesn't
need a parent because she's actually a
full-fledged assassin my favorite thing
about this is that the bosses health bar
says boss yeah he does have name doesn't
have a name just boss just the souls of
a bunch of oh I didn't show the Kazi
pilot you hopefully we get that oh yeah
please please Eric shows the QuickTime
event please what he's running from me
well come back here we'll get the
QuickTime event Hallie's hopefully fill
out one zombie was just hangin out being
a jerk yeah got it boss oh yeah I mean I
guess the game within the game from you
is just to try to keep the combo meter
logo here we go so it's with the
touchpad oh you got swipe up guess what
Dan you got it all just his animations
terrible Jesus Christ split him I'll
split him yeah video games he's not that
that dead second wave that's fine you
know what I'm dead that was only charm
Barra
zi2 chaos available now on the
PlayStation 4 XC game is that having any
other platforms uh I'm not sure
Eric's new Xbox one but maybe I don't
know that's wise the deep dives on only
chime bar you can expect right here from
GameSpot calm
see you next time
you